ci sono quei momenti in cui gli uomini
piangono
e lo so che state piangendo
classica perché siamo su Sound of the
forest che sarebbe il sì anzi il prequel
di the forest quindi the forest 2 è
uscito ragazzi in accesso anticipato lo
vedete qua che lo aggiornano ogni tot
Non vedo l'ora di iniziarlo perché
voglio veramente capire in tutti questi
anni sono quasi dieci anni Eh ragazzi
che diavolo hanno tirato fuori Let's go
ragazzi nuova partita facciamo
difficoltà normale Io mi sono emozionato
per me the forest è uno dei giochi che
ha caratterizzato il mio canale Quindi è
sicuramente nella Top 10 siamo veramente
giocando E come giocare a Happy Wheels 2
che tra l'altro stanno facendo Tra
l'altro Allora partiamo che
ci sembra uno schianto probabilmente Eh
infatti
puffcorp per farne le sigarette
maronne Ah sono su un elicottero io È
bellissimo Cioè siamo passati da dalla
partenza con l'aereo alla partenza con
l'elicottero abbiamo capito che su sta
isola non ci possiamo arrivare via
[__]
esplosa una cuffia Scusate eh via aerea
non ci possiamo arrivare quindi magari
prossima volta a nuoto giorno
non mi sboccare sui pantaloni che sono
nuovi eh Cioè praticamente è sparita una
famiglia che è una famiglia Patton che è
una famiglia di miliardaria A quanto
pare no ed è sparita su quest'isola che
io sappia quindi sono su quest'isola per
cercare la famiglia Patton poi Non
chiedetemi come né perché però vabbè
combatti i tuoi demoni
eh prima dei demoni quelli che ci hanno
sparato poi i demoni sicuramente
ragazzi è normale tranquilli è l'isola
che è così c'è anche l'altra volta era
così tranquillo tanto morite solo voi io
sopravvivo
Ammazza che schianto strano che sta non
c'è stata un'esplosione niente tutto a
posto raga
lui è più bello Era più bianco prima
Porca [__]
Eh ragazzi è una gita di merda
effettivamente la prossima volta
organizzate voi
Ma che schianto Ragazzi ma che schianto
è Scusa ma che succede
Ma ragazzi mi hai fatto di gomma sto
elicottero Ma cos'è mi fa Salvo
Buongiorno
pure pure
Minchia mi sono schiantato con
l'elicottero pure i calci testa di culo
Ammazzati
Non lo so volete pisciarmi in faccia no
che quello è un'altra cosa ragazzi
è arrivato un tizio ma ha ficcato un
cartone se n'è andato a caso a caso
insultatemi la madre non lo so cioè è
arrivato non c'è chi cazzo è quello
Vabbè c'è una partita che non ha un
senso ragazzi a cosa sto giocando i
crimini No vabbè Meno male che c'ho il
beauty Minchia almeno quello
Oh che bello raga Allora è successo di
tuo potrei far finire quel video Ma no è
successo di tutto Ah e si vede che the
forest Eh vabbè fin qua minchia è
qualcuno vivo
Ma lasciamolo pure qua abbiamo dei
nastro adesivo che effettivamente ci
serve Ah Mangiamo prima perché ragazzi
ovviamente dopo lo schianto che succede
Ah posso costruire roba già è un attimo
perché eh
ok Non ho capito cosa ho fatto ma va
bene Allora qua c'è un'elica
questa roba vuvuzela Ma che cacchio c'è
sotto Nokia che diavolo stavamo
trasportando Ma poi Dov'è l'altro tizio
ce n'è solo uno eh fratello Tu sei
quello che era bianco cadaverico l'ha
presa forte la botta lo zio eh calmati
Calmati Calmati calmo calmo
a posto
[Musica]
c'è un coniglio dietro ti prego guardalo
Guarda il coniglio è rinsavisci E vabbè
lasciamolo qua dai fate Tutto a posto
Recupera
bastoni Recupera bastoni e lascia qua Ah
gli impartisco gli ordini ma che ma
cos'è Raga ma che cazzo sta giocando Ma
cosa sto giocando no frate scusami no no
no no non andare da bastoni che avrà
sicuramente ad allenarsi fai un'altra
cosa sgombra riposa Costruisci falò
Ecco così allora non è male
sì
fratello e mi dispiace mi sa che la
botta l'ha presa Eh mi sa che è un po'
messo male che però gli infarti no Eh
ragazzi è incredibile Oh l'attacco del
coniglio mannaro Guardalo Non pensare
cosa succede Questo gioco è l'epicità Mi
serve un bastone qualcosa per fare
un'arma teoricamente
c'ho la tenda più di una Kelvin Kelvin
come cazzo chiami vieni qua eh C'è una
tenda del cioè Possiamo usare questa per
dormire sacchi a pelo cos'è
no prendiamo medicina cazzo come si
sente poi Tachipirina soldi Avevi poi
salvare e dormire perfetto Ah intanto
Salviamo che non è male eh ok Apri
scatole collette de va bene Mi
servirebbe Ecco già vedi che ho un vod
Salve buongiorno c'ho una roccia che
posso usare come arma Quindi vedi che
già posso cacciare già questo uh uh Ho
già trovato una caverna ragazzi bene
bene bene bene C'è anche Gennaro Gennaro
buongiorno eh mi fai sapere tu da
quant'è che sei qua secondo me è più di
5 minuti Comunque c'è una slitta
ma è utilizzabile sta roba no
vedi che fa comunque alpinismo qua non è
proprio gettonato su quest'isola è
servito proprio il casco Eh è servito un
sacco Grazie mille comunque era finita
Non è una di quelle caverne di the
forest classiche che poi vai nel
dall'inferno Però vabbè fai qua un falò
per favore Allora fai un fallo qui so
che te l'ho già fatto fare Non mi odiare
qua Ok ho capito Bravo bravo Hai preso
il pesce magari non sul lago ghiacciato
che si scioglie non è proprio la scelta
migliore perfetto Bravo bravo Kelvin
Vedo che capisci eh a posto Non è
proprio il posto mio cuciniamo il pesce
vediamo se riusciamo a fare ecco qua
Vabbè in cucina con Favij ragazzi nuova
rubrica non mi posso bruciare i soldi
Evviva il capitalismo devo ora Guarda
come se la gode Ma questo tipo di Ali
Una rondella No scherzavo
mi dici ok Mi dispiace no non devi fare
niente Questo schiacciato No non devi
fare niente Scusami ho sbagliato non
stare sul non star
comunque Kelvin è una persona temeraria
e scavo Chiara dal pesce ma si può
mangiare mangio io Eh mangio io Tu non
mangi Che schifo
e Dagliene un pezzo e non è che
è un po' te lo meriti scendiamo subito
Kelvin
Apri i kit di pronto soccorso nel tuo
inventario perché come le faccio
ragazzi a questo
Seleziona l'ingranaggio per aprire il
kit di pronto soccorso
non era il beauty abbiamo il tracciatore
che comunque ragazzi non è non è nel
passato eh abbiamo un tracciatore GPS la
guida la guida Oh cacchio Eccola qua
ha la tenda con l'affare era per fare la
tenda quello che ho buttato per terra
perfetto eh Ah la Madonna quanta roba
Non ho capito come questo possa essere
un prequel Perché sembra molto più nel
futuro rispetto al primo Cioè guarda che
accendino che cazzia accendino è questo
mi fa un po' strano comunque Ragazzi ho
trovato l'accendino ho trovato l'ascia e
lo spazzolino non c'è in tutto questo il
tracciatore cosa serve a vedere dov'è
Kelvin vedo che comunque mi segna delle
cose andiamo direttamente Allora dovevi
segna leggo mi segna un sacco di cose in
realtà ci sono anche ehm dei punti con
la i non so cosa siano andiamo a vedere
ragazzi che bella la foresta allora
e muori ma come cazzo che non muore la
selvaggina in sto gioco Ragazzi ma
Scusatemi
Adesso mangiamo una barretta proteica
perché Minchia non è possibile
ok
e mangiare abbiamo mangiato le bacche
raga è rischiosissimo mangiarle Infatti
lo sapevo non abbiamo nel culo Allora
qua rilevo un'altra caverna
Ok C'è un Gollum
Picchio picchialo
dardaccio
vedi che questi sono questi sono questi
agenti in parco demonio Questa è gente
impalata ti serve della roba poi vado
via
Porca [__] via via via via via via via
via via via via via via ci sono teschi
prigio tanto non mi hanno attaccato si
sono attaccati sotto Kelvin Kelvin dove
Cosa fai Sei pazzo scemo quello Ah c'è
una caverna
non mi conviene mai entrare là dentro
ragazzi Lasciamo stare vediamo poi più
avanti vedo un qualcosa Beh vabbè
ragazzi ci sono accampamenti però eh
Vedo accampamenti di gente non pacifica
quindi lasciamo stare però vedo un
segnalino verde quello Porca [__] sono
cascato in un ruscello mi conviene
andare a vedere che cos'è perché ve lo
vedo bello lampeggiante io
eh raga S'è messo a piovere vabbè allora
andiamo sul segnalino verde che non
posso fare un metro che trovo gente
Ma vattene a [__] va' minchia
Non ho armi Cioè ce li ho Ma non
funzionano ho trovato un burrone siamo
in Death stranding va bene
Siamo quasi arrivati al segnalino verde
ragazzi che non è male perché siamo
anche vicino al mare
buongiorno e arrivederci non so se ha
visto ma piove non le conviene star
fuori eh
non ingaggiamo raga Che già sono nella
cacca così Kelvin corrri possibilmente
più di lui sono quasi arrivato al
segnalino verde Raga non so cosa sia
L'abbiamo quasi raggiunto Kelvin ci
siamo Eccolo cos'è che ci dovrebbe
essere Scusami eh
oh c'è un Caddy c'è un Caddy Cosa ci fa
un Kelvin è tuo è una Eh fa parte della
storia non lo so che dovrei fare questo
Kelvin non sembra esserci niente attorno
al suo Katy un po' strano siamo arrivati
al segnalino verde Comunque è un Caddy
abbandonato quindi non ho la più pallida
idea di che cosa serva Facciamo così
andiamo sul mare sulla spiaggia ci
facciamo un bel rifugio questo sarà
ragazzi il nostro rifugio stabile Eccoci
qua Allora innanzitutto possiamo bere
che non è male
perfetto c'è la roba in mare Ragazzi
allora facciamo così facciamo un
bell'accampamento in spiaggia che almeno
stiamo tranquilli quanti tronchi devo
raccogliere per far sta roba Vabbè forse
ci conviene farla Giusto nella foresta
perché almeno è più semplice prenderla
legna Eh ragazzi però comunque vicino
alla spiaggia perché almeno la
possibilità di staccarmi questa è la
cosa principale ve lo specolo qua pe
guarda Perfetto Perfetto Questo è un
posto perfetto
Ok allora la casa la casetta è [__]
secondo me però dobbiamo buttare giù
Kelvin dove cazzo è quando serve
trappola per animali piccola ragazzi
serve tantissimo sta roba qua vicino a
casa che almeno usciamo e ci abbiamo la
cena pronta ecco questa qua serve
tantissimo ragazzi eccoti qua intanto
costruisci un falò e se no qua non
mangiamo Ah finisci struttura la può
fare lui Ah Facciamo così tanto fai un
fallo e lo fai qua mi fai la struttura
nel mentre che io vado ad esplorare si
può fare no esattamente Grazie mille
Bravo Brother dai fuoco a tutto
Possibilmente non a casa nostra Ti sei
dato fuoco da solo vabbè tanto lo sei
abituato Costruisci
riparo
un riparo proprio al volo giusto per
stanotte perché sennò non ce la facciamo
a far sta roba Uhm No no vabbè ma non
puoi fare il rifugio sopra
fratello le basi Minchia
Vabbè ignifuga Sta tenda Bravo Ok bravo
Ok bravo Ok va bene sai comunque avere
che sei studiato sei Bear Grylls altro
guarda come si impegna per pescare
Guardalo che metodo di pesca è questo
Scusa
Guarda che roba
ma bravissimo ma Bravissimo
Oh
non mangiare Non lo mangiare così Ma sì
scemo tu la cosa che devi fare è finire
la struttura Quindi tu fai questo e la
tua giornata deve essere questa Bravo
Eccoci qua E chi s'è visto s'è visto
perfetto la trappola per animali c'è
anche ogni animali Però vabbè allora lui
intanto finisce la struttura ho dato un
lavoro a Kelvin andiamo tranquillamente
a esplorare perché adesso siamo a posto
la prima cosa che vorrei vedere è che
cosa c'è in acqua vedete che c'è un coso
lì mi dà anche il punto interrogativo Io
andrei subito a vedere che cos'è quello
ragazzi che se non è importante andiamo
là e poi vediamo le caverne Quelle sono
molto più schery come cosa più che altro
vorrei craftarmi un'arma raga perché
questa qua non leva niente A meno che
non fosse perché magari con la
stanchezza sai Levi di meno Questo non
lo so non lo so Ragazzi c'è un barile di
inquinamento anche su un'isola deserta
pure non so se nuotare mi fa perdere ci
sono gli squali qua che ragazze sono gli
squali sono morto eh
pesci
premi mica con le mani Cioè comunque se
non ci fosse Kelvin io sarei nella messa
andando a nuoto a vedere Cos'è
quell'affare ragazzi è che non ho altro
modo Sperando che non ci siano squali
Perché nell'altro gioco c'erano gli
squali è un corso di salto Porco due che
cazzo è
che è successo la morso qualcuno Porca
vacca sali su stappare sali su staffare
Sali sali sopra veloce
Minchia cos'è sta a fare qua
porca vacca
Che minchia era
Ciao ragazzi giorno ah ah ah
quindi ragazzi Spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto questo primo episodio di di
Sons of the forest è molto fatto bene Ci
sono un sacco di cose da scoprire
ovviamente sia la trama che tutto il
resto intanto comunque è pieno di
misteri le foreste è sempre stato pieno
di misteri quindi scopriremo insieme per
ora il video vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
come se questo video Vi è piaciuto
lasciate un commento e un mi piace anche
per i social che condividetelo nella
descrizione Vi aspetto per l'episodio 2
qua sul canale E noi come sempre ci
vediamo ad un prossimo video bella
ragazzi